الدرجات الحرمان العاليه الحقولها البشر
همم اطفال بعض الاشخاص ابناءهم وابائهم في
ظروف مروعه جدا همم
الصناديق
بمترى في متر
وادخلوا
وبعد ذلك
وكل الحديث عن الاسلام
والنزاهه والكرامه البشر لا توجد اي حقوق
ولا اي كرامه بدون اي احترام رماهم في
مقابر جماعيه
او حتى في حفر فيها الكلاب
والحيوانات الميته مع النفايات الاخرى
فمن قد يفعله امرا مثل ذلك في اي كون وفي
اي بعد وفي اي زمان
بامكاني اي شخص ان يفخر
بطفل يفعل ذلك
فعلينا ان نسمي الامور على حالها وان نحقق
في من هو المسؤول عن ذلك وكل هذا الحرمان
ولا يمكن يتعامل معهم
بالمجرده الكلمات بل يجب ان يكون ذلك اظن
اطار القانون وتوفير الادله
والقضاه المستقلين يقارورون بعدها هل هم
مسؤولون ام لا لذلك اعتقد بانه لا يخص فقط
ولم
فيرانهم بعد ذلك هو الاب الذي ما عاد
يستطيع ان يعيش في البيت ولا يتحمل هذا
المنزل الذي يجب ان يكون فيه امنا بسبب كل
ذكرياته وذكريات اطفاله الذين اخطفوا خذوا
منه او حتى الامهات
وقلت لك بكل وضوح لمجلس الامن الام التي
في نهايه احد اجتماعات كانت ساكته وهادئه
جدا وهي تبكي وتقول الحمد لله انا همم
اقبل به اراده الله ولكن فقط اريد ان اعرف
ما حصل لابني اريد ان اعرف اين هو وما حصل
نركز عليها امام المسجد
خاصه بالمعانات والالم بينما كل يرغبون به
وعايشه حياتهم بسلام فا
عام
نجتمعه
الجديده القانونيه وفقا للي مبادئ العالم
الاسلامي وافريقيا وامريكا اللاتينيه
واسيا واوروبا والغير المدفوعه بالدين بل
مدفوعه القانونيه وهي بشكل اساسي مدفوعه
باحساسينا المشتركين الانسانيتنا هل نرغب
مستقبل اطفال